how are you making sure that your
secrets are securely stored
so that you can avoid data breaches as
well as chaos in your devops workflows
hi i'm alex greer with the ibm cloud
team and before i get started
make sure to like and subscribe now what
is a secret
a secret is a digital credential that is
going to allow entities to communicate
and perform actions on a service this
discrete piece of information
keeps that access point secure so let's
take a look at the
the way in which this paradigm exist so
let's start with
an entity here
needs to access some sort of service
we'll leave it a little ambiguous for
right now but some sort of service
so in order to properly communicate with
the service and be able to take the
action that it needs to to get its job
done
this entity is going to need to
communicate to this service two things
one who it is so that service can
understand
what or who it's interacting with two
it's going to have to know the set of
permissions that it should grant
in the context of its service
with these the service can now properly
allow that entity to interact with them
so how we enable this is with something
we call
secret
so now with this dynamic establish let's
move into an example with users so for
users
we'll say user here's our entity and
we'll say our service here
let's just say they it's a developer and
they happen to need read or write access
so they're interacting with a
development repo in order to do that
so in order to gain that access again
coming back to the
um to the need we have authorization and
permission how it's going to communicate
it specifically in this circumstance
is by giving it user credentials
now that user can interact with that dev
repo in the way that they need to to get
their job done
now looking at a cloud cloud native
application story
we have a lot of microservices that have
to talk to each other so
let's look at that so let's just call it
service a
needs to interact with a database
called db and grab a piece of specific
information that it needs to
to to get its job done so what it needs
in the form of a secret here
is what we call db configs
again this db config is going to allow
it to have
the right communication with the service
saying this is who i am
and this is what i came here to
accomplish
but now that we have our user
credentials and our db configs as
example of secrets
we realize the vulnerability that can be
created here if these were to fall into
the wrong hands
and this is why it's so important to
establish
a centralized place to manage all these
things as we build out more and more
applications microservices
and we have more of these that problem
becomes more complex
and if it falls into the wrong hands how
is it protected
um how did we block it from getting to
that point how was that data isolated
when we look at the the damage that this
can cause we're looking in the millions
of dollars for example for a data breach
and in terms of developer operations if
you're not properly managing these
forget even the case in which a bad
actor hasn't been involved but it can be
confusing for teams to use this
so what we need to do is make sure that
we have it again centralized
and properly stored so that we can
leverage these secrets in the right way
and they can properly communicate with
services
okay now let's take a look at the next
layer of of the onion
in a more complicated example
now let's go back to jane the enterprise
developer
jane are we'll say e dev
here needs again to have access to that
development repo that she was referring
to
earlier let's just go ahead and call
this maybe
it's it's github so what she needs to be
able to do is have
write access
and so she's going to give it she's
going to need to request the information
that's going to give her access to that
right role
so that's where a secrets manager
service comes in
in a perfect complementary fashion
so a secrets manager service
can securely store these credentials
along with
other types of secrets in a centralized
way for her to be able to access or
maybe other services to access like
we'll see in a second
but what it's done is it's given her the
peace of mind
that her user credentials are
securely stored and now she can worry
about
authenticating and with the service and
getting her job done because secrets
manager is going to take care of that
for her
however what's really important for a
secrets manager service to do
is interact with the cloud service
providers imr identity and
access management service so this
i am is going to be the source of truth
allowing secrets manager to one
authenticate
who she is and so that it can pass it
down to github and secondarily
also allow for her to get the right set
of roles based on the paradigm that they
have within
their im service so with this we now
understand what it's like for a user
to get the right permission and be able
to access
the tool of their choice or their
service and be able to do this in the
context of
using a secrets manager service but now
let's look what it's like
for a service to interact with another
service
and potentially where data bridges could
be harmful
now let's look at our service to service
example
so what we have to start with is that we
have
let's just call it a lending application
so lending app
and this lending app is going to want to
request permissions
to be able to access again we were
talking about a database earlier
let's be a little bit more specific this
database that it needs to access and a
given table within this database
has necessary information to give to its
model in order to be able to make a
judgment on whether or not they want to
provide a consumer alone
so we're going to call this a profile
database so within here we have
profile db
and we know that the set of permissions
that we want to grant are going to be
read permissions for table
a so again where are we going to
store the secret that's ultimately going
to give us access to give us access to
authentication
and ultimately to the set of permissions
that we need here so that's again going
to be the secrets manager service
provided
and that service needs to talk to cloud
im again so now that we've got this
established
what type of credential do we have here
the credential that we have
is called a dbconfig
so let's think about the scenario we
just walked through this db config
allows this lending application a
service to be able to have
read access or be able to take a
specific set of information from a given
table
within a database that has some ip data
and some other highly sensitive
information in it
so in a scenario in which these db can
fix are not stored properly
or the service that they stored in is
compromised
what we ultimately get is a pretty
catastrophic scenario for the provider
because the provider of the service of
this lending application then has to go
and tell its customer
that a bad actor was able to take
advantage of access that it got
wrongfully to its db config and that
dbconfig ultimately
allowed that bad actor to steal their
data and do whatever they wanted with it
against that customer so what we can do
to mitigate it again
is store it in a safe location where bad
actors do not have access and you have
the level of data isolation
that you're comfortable with as an
enterprise so that's where we have
secrets manager services
so again secrets manager services
help to ensure the secure storage of
secrets
so that you don't have to worry about
data breaches from lost credentials or
from other types of secrets
and ultimately it makes it a little more
efficient for the management
of your your secrets while you're going
through your devops operations
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe
and don't forget
you can grow your skills and earn a
badge with ibm cloud labs which are free
browser-based interactive kubernetes
labs